let's bring in the Alabama quarterback
to a tongue of AI Aloha good morning -
how are you I'm good good morning who's
your favorite team growing up NFL team I
was a Dallas Cowboys fan growing up my
entire team my entire family was Cowboys
and so we loved the Cowboys did you meet
anybody did you have a favorite player
um I think the only person I've ever
I've ever got to meet that was on a
cowboy team that I can remember is
Marcus Spears and Alan Ball okay not not
necessarily the big names there but and
then your your favorite college team
growing up was was probably a USC
they're there on the west coast you know
closer to home so and that was the team
growing up too and then Matt Leinart
left-handed I'm sure that that was one
of your idols oh yeah is he a funny
story when I was when I was young my dad
chose my number for me so like I started
out with number 11 because Matt Leinart
and like it went all the way up until my
sophomore year where I couldn't pick
number 11 going into my bar city season
because there's a senior who had number
11 so I had to choose between 13 and 19
and I just took 13 I just stuck with it
from there on and then you know link
iffen mentioned this to me that you know
there was a time where they thought you
were gonna transfer from Alabama and
maybe go to USC how close were you to
doing that well I mean I it was it was
it was really close I think because I
mean you know I I wanted my parents to
see me play my parents wanted to see me
play and I mean just just doing things
for my parents you know making my
parents happy and proud was probably the
biggest thing I wanted to do and I
couldn't do it on the sideline so yeah
they'd come to watch you you know stand
on the sidelines not exactly exciting
for mom and dad when when did you know
you were good Oh
I'm not too sure um probably wind
probably went outside I was winning when
I was little I can't really remember
remember too far back but not too sure
yeah but I wonder if there was that
moment that like a play or a game where
you really want you know what I could I
could do this at a big-time school or I
could do this professionally you never
had one of those moments not really I
think I think it was more so a mindset
thing because of the work ethic that's
been instilled in me and you know like a
little brother you know from from my dad
so I think it's just more of a mindset
thing like every time I have the
opportunity to step in you know the game
or you know have an opportunity to play
against a really good team
I got a performance expected of us to
perform so clear something up were you
born right-handed and then became
left-handed yes sir I am I am right
dominant I write with my left eye kick
all right I write with my right eye kid
with my right eye you with my right eye
do everything with my right except sir
only in shooting so how can you how well
can you throw right-handed it's all
right it's not too bad I mean it it was
almost natural but you know you could
roll out right and throw right if it's
probably like a five-yard you could be
like mahomes you would be the
left-handed version of mahomes when's
the last time you got yelled at by Coach
Saban hmm probably this past this past
Sunday or this past Monday probably this
past Monday yeah and what you do
we had good bad nugget and I kind of
took a sack in two minutes
this past game so and I got on me so
okay so not that bad I mean that
pretty good if you have a hard time
remembering then we had him on two weeks
ago and I asked your coach
what if you parked in his parking spot
this is what Coach Saban said I probably
have a discussion with them you know
sometimes when key players on your team
you know do things even though you you
really have great relationship with them
and it's kind of not a big deal you know
you also have to realize that especially
when the key players do something
everybody else on the team is watching
so you can park there how do you think
that would go if you parked in coach
savings parking spot oh I don't think
it'd go good I don't think anyone anyone
would try to party because favorite spot
Josh Jacobs told told us his story the
you know former running back yeah that
he did you hear about this that Josh
said that Coach saving and will joke
occasionally and then he mentioned deez
nutz you know he was talking sausage
josh has he done that to you to her
personally I've heard you know joke you
know I'm like whoa that was that goes
never know that someone else but I mean
okay can you confirm that story though
to it with Josh Jacob yeah I wouldn't I
wouldn't doubt that goes there said that
is you know usually when people are
having a bad day because they will kind
of cheer em up by saying something
that's out of the ordinary you know to
make them laugh what's your mouth is I
wanted out that's something he would say
why do I assume you can surf why do you
assume I can surf because I'm for a boy
yeah but is it true yes actually cancer
are you good I wouldn't say I'm good but
I mean I can get up on that on board you
know and right away then but if I said
introduce you to dr. Scott or Kelly
Slater Oh that'd be that'd be dope well
you got a pic here
I mean tagged AK is man so you know he's
Meredith Oh Kelly's pretty good too
you know he's probably the greatest
surfer of all time I'm not too big into
surfing okay all right that makes sense
what classes you got today I got a calm
calm class calm 4:55 class today um and
I got astronomy what's your major I'm a
PR communications major okay if not for
football what would you be doing to get
into it to probably like sports
broadcasting I like I like talking about
it like sports so okay can you can you
stand in front of a lot of people and
deliver you know five minutes of sports
five minutes of sports yeah yes sir I
actually had to do that in an advanced
public speaking class and then we had
this rhetoric class as well where we had
to go in front of like like well we had
to go in public and like nope I ended up
talking like you know on the steps of I
think it was like our gorgeous library
and like people are walking by you know
and then you got to speak like loud and
you know your entire class is there and
like just normal students are walking by
listen to you and knowing that it was me
everyone kind of came to listen yeah but
that's great experience for you not only
helps you I don't know how often you're
interviewed at Alabama but if you know
you get the opportunity to play in the
NFL it's going to come in handy they're
standing up in front of those members of
the media yeah no yeah it definitely
does help um but I think the classroom
setting is probably the hardest one of
the hardest things because everyone's
paying attention everyone's looking at
you and then
for a bad public speaking they kind of
they kind of look for a lot of the
things that you don't do as well so
you're fidgeting a lot if you're not
making as much eye contact with the
crowd your you know your gestures how
much you're moving you're pacing good
for you you know things like that
yeah because it's not easy but you know
those who are really good make it look
easy therefore everybody wants to do it
yes yeah I mean it's like when I watch
you play it looks pretty easy what you
do is it it's well it's the guy that I'm
surrounded with you know it's not more
so me I they make my job that much
easier especially especially the line I
mean at bat position that is the most
thankless position I think in sports and
you playing a line you you work out hard
really hard I could say we all work out
hard but I mean you guys work out hard
and how do you how do you kick step and
you you take a guy from a cool speed at
you like you know how do you take a guy
on like that this is this isn't this is
these aren't kids you know you're you
having the bike these are grown man you
know and having to move guys like that
is what I mean that's that's good can
you can you go clear this up do your
receivers do Rock Paper Scissors to see
who gets to go out on these long
touchdown passes is is that is that
story real well I think I think they
vented a good amount last year but it's
only become evident this year wait wait
so how do they do it they do it on the
sidelines to see who gets to go in they
they do it either on the sidelines or
usually we have TV timeouts before we
come out surveys and during those TVs on
my hooks you know and I mean it's it's
usually okay it's a shot play right here
you know that's let's rock paper
scissors for this he's gonna get the
ball so wait whoever wins Rock Paper
Scissors is who you're going to throw it
to
most of the time they're usually gonna
be because that's how we've been
practicing you know that that person is
gonna I'm gonna get the bond then you
know if they don't get the bobbin it's
nothing big
I never wore your Jersey to class oh no
sir yeah I'm not I'm not too too big of
a fan of myself you know to do all of
that as a professor ever ask for an
autograph
yes oh and you give it to him yeah I
mean I can help your grade right
hey it's great to have you on congrats
for your success and good luck for the
rest of the season more importantly good
luck with that
school work there appreciate that thank
you so much that's a - a tongue of I'll
own Alabama quarterback for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]